tô treinando nada acho que eu
preciso gravar vídeo meu Deus eu vou
lutar com P pó que que eu fiz isso hein
vou apanhar tanto ele não vai me matar
ele não é doido Regina rasgou o sofá
Será que ela tá zangada comigo minha mãe
brigou com a vizinha por causa do Angar
do pé de coco que entrou pra frente do
quintar da gente que que eu tô fazendo
da minha vida hein será que eu tô
querendo provar algo para alguém T vi no
site fofox TV oficiais que eu sou
inseguro será que eu sou inseguro
preciso marcar terapia terapia vai ser o
com Popó idá Vel mas é 1 milhão
de dólar Mano quanto é que tá o dólar
hein acho que tá C conto falaram que ia
baixar o dólar bom para mim né que
converte Reis mas de que que adianta a
gasolina tá s com R 2500 você encha o
tanque de uma ronda bit lembra meus
amigos de tomar segunda dose uma dose é
num braço a outra é no outro vota
impressa é minha pomba